yeah welcome to this video I play d4 and
see what happens in this five-minute
game yeah everybody plays the Greenfeld
and I don't have a really great handsome
and my video series I'm recommended the
slide which I really like but also don't
know so well in tournament chess I'm
very often play Knight f3 or C form
first move so I don't really get them a
Greenfeld a 60 some so-called Hungarian
variation attending a quick b5 and see
if I've Queen a foursome rare answer but
I saw this move recently and wanted to
give it a try so Knight to d7 mmm so on
of course he wants to get the spawn bag
there should be three covering the pawn
the side probably answered with nijah
form and then this doesn't look too
great but okay if I let him take um
let's clear that dumb this is some not
really good maybeee 5v5 95 I probably
have some technical way to to play Queen
somewhere Quincy form that he just takes
immediately
great now probably I'm justified okay ya
know 97 I i guess but maybe you can go
95 in and yeah maybe 95 okay the daily
different move not not bad probably just
attacking this pawn so on maybe Bishop
to g5 attacking 7-under maybe I'll get
in Rupp the one with the temple hmm so
on there's some technical problem with
the should be 795
b5 there should be seven rook e8 Bishop
d8 and then it's got discoveries well
this is some this is true now probably a
little get some development going yeah
he's just playing the most aggressive
principal moves down probably outsides
good also yeah if i take we texted us
bishops III threatened so i need to to
go for this as strange as it may be
I'm threatening 97 96 or 95 winning the
Queen for couple of minor pizzas f6 I he
runs into this check so maybe am I get
something only seven
oh man I don't have to i don't have
enough time should be seven SI you
should be seven yeah okay i need to do
this anyway and I'm what I'm thinking
about like Knight f6 next 9 s6 Bishop f6
Bishop f7 king of 1787 but he's got Luke
a king to King 36 m she moves the Queen
now then none the slider son is on
yeah but he needs to move the Queen ER
and 27 hmm it's not working Knight f6 06
/ f7 king i also got the King g7 for
example
and don't don't have a move this is a
problem time money yeah all my pieces
are hanging so it's e41 and everything's
hanging so just just winning for black I
mean the time also was a disaster yeah
really don't we didn't get what he was
thinking about concerned this is a very
easy one down so I can take the five
everything once Bishop c4 there grabbin
night c4 so i can actually resign this
doesn't make any sense yeah I don't
really know him how how this is played
Queen a three-year but I didn't know oh
yeah actually the Queen D through a
queen a three is right yeah forgot that
i have 95 and this sum here i was
thinking this this and now again this
move but i have i have good moves here
Bishop g5 on 95 and this is interesting
I mean it's not the end of the world for
black but I can I can play this so I
didn't
after what I played a bloody five yeah
Nyjah force just just good taking
attacking if I fanta I don't have a move
really it's also much better than none
97 or 95 which I I was thinking about 95
but this is stronger now we five is just
under tech and I don't really have a
move I mean okay we should be five then
then he played 95 which is very cool of
course I cannot if you look at this took
now I played Bishop c4 just because I
don't have a move rookie one is better
okay but I mean this is some just not
working and this means I'm in
desperation mode here nanti I'm just
lost anything I have no move I mean it
had spent some time and would have lost
on time also but i have no move so an
opening opening disaster he refuted this
nicely yeah thanks for watching